à 31 ans le skipper louis burton vit
actuellement son deuxième vendée globe
laurent boli taille dans l'océan indien
sur son imoca bureau vallée le
navigateur affronte en ce moment le
froid venu dans l'antarctique et les
baleines une balade une bonne allure
quoi aussi proche
5 / développeurs bush
vous me dire que tu comme ça ça doit
faire plusieurs tonnes la baleine et le
break et le skipper qui semblait un
petit
un petit un peu plus de 15000 kilomètres
de louis burton sa femme la navigatrice
servane escoffier vie la course entre
les studios de télévision à paris et sa
maison à saint malo en bretagne on la
vit surtout intensément et sans coupure
jour et nuit et on suit les moindres
classement
on attend le moindre e mail pour savoir
s'il a d'autres problèmes si tout va
bien et on sait que tout va bien une
heure après tu peux avoir une grosse
galère donc c'est vrai qu'on se réjouit
de chaque 24 heures qui passent pour
communiquer avec louis burton sa femme
là au téléphone une à deux fois par
semaine et lui envoie environ 5 mails
par jour ça va aussi bien des raconter
ce que font nos enfants que de que des
parties techniques et puis aussi c'est
l'univers de divertir de le tenir
informé de la vie à terre d actualité
louis burton devrait être de retour dans
un peu moins de deux mois sauf incident
le skipper est actuellement neuvième de
cette 8e édition du vendée globe